I mean I feel fine I just cry myself to
sleep every night yeah that's totally
normal Kourtney Kardashian just served
up some major Keeping Up with the
Kardashians nostalgia with a little help
from Addison Rae I'm like watching the
Kardashians and I'm like oh my gosh
I wonder what that'd be like to
experience that and so I like I get it
and um it is crazy that I'm in that
position now yep just a few months after
Addison told et all of that I mean I'm a
fan girl the tic-tock star teamed up
with a pooch founder to reenact one of
courts most iconic scenes from the hit
reality show I feel like I want to jump
out of my skin like I'm so crazy like I
just I can't take it you know the one it
was 2018 and court had a super emotional
convo with her pal Larsa Pippen about
taking hormone shots to prep for
freezing her eggs I mean I feel fine I
just cry myself to sleep every night
yeah that's totally normal yeah that
seems I mean I feel fine I just cry
myself to sleep every night yeah that's
totally normal but they didn't stop
there
remember this mother-daughter moment
between Kris Jenner and Khloe Kardashian
you know what a thong I mean not a not
in public
oh wow you are conservative yeah they
tik-tok to the hell out of that one too
you already have this well I can't wear
it cuz do you see the back it's the
thumb what do you think I am you know
where the thong I mean not a not in
public
oh wow you are conservative Addison in
court also did some choreo in the closet
and the nineteen-year-olds even teamed
up with Courtney's ten-year-old son
Mason who showed off some pretty
impressive moves this isn't the first
time court and Addison have joined
forces right here with Addison I'm so
excited I am so excited this will be a
really fun workout in May court invited
the tic-tock star to collab on a push
video where Addison broke down her
signature booty workout I start feeling
it so much the fire is burning good
thing I did not do but yesterday Addison
and Courtney the Internet's newest
besties I love it when et caught up with
Addison in February quartz little sister
Kendall had just started following the
teen on tick-tock and Addison was shook
Kendall Jenner just recently joined
tick-tock yeah like yesterday she
followed me that's so cool as for what's
next well the social media star told ET
she has her sights set on stardom in the
next year I really am pushing to get
into acting really hard right now so
I've been on a lot of auditions and like
castings and stuff like that so
hopefully in the next year I'll be
casted in a movie or TV show which would
be so insane because that's kind of like
always been my dream just like be on the
big screen stranger things would be
really cool to be on but honestly
anything